Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a SQUARESPACE.
Ya sean páginas web, tiendas online o herramientas
de marketing y analíticas… SQUARESPACE
es la plataforma todo en uno para construir
una excelente presencia online y operar tu
negocio.
Y ahora, vamos con el vídeo.
Seguramente pienses que estas imágenes son
de un paisaje de Suiza o de Austria ¿Verdad?
Pues nada de eso… este paisaje pertenece
a Italia.
Y seguramente pensarás que, estando en Italia,
la gente que vive por aquí hablará italiano
¿Verdad?
¡Pues tampoco!
Estas imágenes son de Tirol del Sur.
Y por estas zonas, la lengua más común es
el alemán.
Muchos pensaríais que el idioma que la gente
en Italia habla italiano pero… la realidad
es mucho más compleja.
El país de la pizza y Rocco Siffredi está
lleno de idiomas y dialectos que no tienen
nada que ver entre ellos.
Por ejemplo, el veneciano no se parece en
nada al Siciliano.
Es decir, que los contrastes en Italia son
mucho más pronunciados de lo que podríamos
pensar.
Y lo mismo ocurre con la política ¿Os imagináis
que un partido de extrema izquierda hiciera
un gobierno de coalición con un partido de
extrema derecha?
Por ejemplo, a los que nos veis desde España…
¿Os imagináis a VOX pactando con Podemos?
Suena raro ¿Verdad?
Pues más o menos eso es lo que ha pasado
en Italia ¿No me creéis?
Pues atentos…
…
Italia es un país de contradicciones.
Por un lado, hablamos del país donde está
el Vaticano: un país que mantiene el respeto
por las tradiciones y el catolicismo.
Por el otro lado, se trata del país que tuvo
a Berlusconi de presidente.
Por un lado, Italia es uno de los países
más sobrerregulados de toda Europa.
Por el otro, Italia tiene un peso enorme de
la economía sumergida.
Pero, sin duda alguna, la mayor contradicción
de Italia es su gobierno; una coalición de
extrema derecha y extrema izquierda.
Y ya sé lo que me vais a decir muchos…
“a ver, Fonseca, que el Movimiento 5 estrellas
no es, exactamente, izquierda”.
Y tenéis razón.
Sería un error decir que el Movimiento 5
estrellas es el equivalente italiano a Podemos,
por ejemplo.
Pero tienen más cosas en común de lo que
podríamos imaginar.
Para empezar, también son un partido que
se presenta como una fuerza en contra del
establishment.
Proponen cosas como una renta básica para
las clases más bajas y su organización interna
se basa en un sistema asambleario.
Es más, al igual que Podemos en sus inicios,
el Movimiento 5 estrellas también propone
reducir el salario de los políticos para
que puedan empatizar realmente con los trabajadores.
Y lo mismo ocurre con LEGA ¿Es un partido
de derechas como pueda serlo VOX en España?
Pues no exactamente.
Ahora bien, coinciden en muchas propuestas
como el rechazo a los inmigrantes o el nacionalismo
¡Y esto es lo más divertido de todo!
Podríamos decir que LEGA es una contradicción
en sí mismo.
Ahora defienden el orgullo de ser italiano.
Pero, en sus comienzos, eran un partido regionalista
que quería separarse de Italia.
Por seguir con la comparación con España,
sería como si JOAQUIM TORRA se levantara
un día y se convirtiera en SANTIAGO ABASCAL:
Y ya sé lo que os preguntaréis ahora…
¿Por qué le prestamos tanta atención a
Italia?
Pues veréis, lo primero es que Italia es
la tercera economía de la EUROZONA.
Y resulta que tienen la peor recesión de
toda Europa.
Si Italia está en crisis, es posible que
toda Europa sufra los efectos.
Y si Europa está en crisis, puede arrastrar
al mundo entero con ella.
Así que da igual si veis este vídeo desde
México, Argentina o Colombia… todo esto
también os puede afectar ¡Pero no sólo
eso!
Esta extraña pareja que gobierna Italia podría
sentar un precedente para otros países.
La política y las ideologías están cambiando
y muchas fórmulas que antes eran impensables,
ahora están gobernando países ¡No sólo
hablo de Italia!
Por ejemplo, en Grecia, SYRIZA, que es un
partido muy de izquierdas, llegó al gobierno
de la mano de ANEL, que es un partido muy
de derechas.
Y algo parecido ocurre en República Checa,
donde los comunistas están en coalición
con un partido anti inmigración y un partido
liberal ¿Es esto posible?
Pues parece ser que sí.
Hace 10 años, a nadie se le ocurriría.
Pero las cosas están cambiando mucho en todas
partes.
Así que la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es
¿Cómo es posible que dos partidos, que en
principio son antagónicos, terminen gobernando
juntos?
¿Puede funcionar esta fórmula para sacar
a Italia de la crisis?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
DE LA LIGA NORTE A… LA LIGA
Como decíamos antes, Italia es un país con
más de 34 idiomas y dialectos distintos.
Y las diferencias no terminan aquí.
En la economía pasa lo mismo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el Sur de Italia
tiene una tasa de desempleo de casi el 20%.
Hasta hace pocos años, era normal en Sicilia
tener cortes de agua a diario.
Y la mayor parte de la gente trabaja en la
agricultura por salarios bastante bajos.
En otras palabras, es una zona relativamente
pobre.
Sin embargo, el norte de Italia es un país
distinto.
Hablamos del lugar donde nacieron los Ferrari
y los Lamborguini.
Ciudades como Milán son conocidas en todo
el mundo por la moda, la industria y por tener
un nivel de vida comparable al de las zonas
más ricas de Alemania.
Por supuesto que su tasa de desempleo no llega
ni a un tercio de la de sus vecinos del Sur
y la renta es casi el doble.
Pues bien, esta brecha entre el Sur y el Norte
es lo que inspiró la creación de la LIGA
NORTE en los años 90.
Su fundador fue este señor que veis en la
pantalla, Umberto Bossi.
En un principio, Bossi quería que su región,
la Lombardía, que por cierto, es donde está
Milan, fuera un país independiente de Italia.
Pero un buen día este señor se levantó
por la mañana y dijo “oye, ¿Y si nos juntáramos
varios partidos regionalistas y creamos la
madre de todos los partidos separatistas?”.
Y así es como nacio la LIGA NORTE, una formación
con un único objetivo: romper Italia en dos
mitades.
Y digo su único objetivo porque en el resto
de temas tenían división de opiniones.
Había gente de izquierdas y de derechas.
Lo único que tenían todos en común era
el odio a Italia y el amor por este nuevo
país que querían crear que se llamaba PADANIA.
Por supuesto, como todo movimiento separatista,
los Padanos también reivindicaban sus diferencias
culturales.
Pero, en este caso, su discurso se centraba
más en la economía.
Umberto Bossi decía que Roma estaba robando
a las regiones del norte para dárselo a las
del Sur.
Y, creedme, su odio a Italia haría PUIGDEMONT
pareciera Bertín Osborne ¿No me creéis?
Pues atentos.
“Cuando veo la bandera italiana, me entran
ganas de cagar.
Utilizo la tricolor para limpiarme el culo”
–Umberto Bossi
Es más, por seguir con el paralelismo, el
señor Bossi también declaró a su querida
Padania como país independiente de Italia
en 1996.
Pero por muy separatistas que fueran, la Liga
Norte seguía siendo un partido italiano.
Y eso significa que tenían que jugar con
las reglas italianas y presentarse en las
elecciones al parlamento italiano.
Así que, para expandir su influencia, Umberto
Bossi y su Liga Norte se convirtieron en uno
de los principales aliados de los gobiernos
de Berlusconi.
Y creedme, esta alianza les vino de perlas.
De repente, los votantes de la Liga Norte
veían cómo su voto era muy útil.
A pesar de ser un partido regional, tenían
el suficiente capital político a nivel nacional
como para conseguir un montón de beneficios
para sus regiones.
“Despierta Padania!
Con la Liga Norte, en contra de los ladrones
de Roma”
Pero, por muy influyentes que fueran, a duras
penas pasaban del 8% de los votos.
Es decir, que dentro del contexto italiano,
Liga Norte seguía siendo un partido pequeño.
Sin embargo, todo esto cambió en el año
2012.
En este momento es cuando Umberto Bossi sufrió
un infarto cerebral y le sucedió este señor
que veis en pantalla: MATEO SALVINI.
Salvini venía con una agenda llena de cambios.
De entrada, cambió el nombre del partido,
que pasó de llamarse LEGA NORDE a “LEGA”
a secas.
Y todo esto era más que un cambio cosmético.
De repente, el enemigo dejaron de ser los
ladrones de Roma a ser… ¡Los inmigrantes!
“Más inmigrantes significa más criminals”
Salvini está trabajando en un plan de repatriación
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué pasó con todo ese
sentimiento anti italiano?
¿No se supone que Roma era el mayor enemigo
de los Padanos?
Pues, como diría TER, la Liga Norte hizo
un Plot Twist en toda regla.
And what happened to that anti Italian feeling?
Aren’t they the biggest enemy of Padanians
anymore?
Well… if you think a party cannot change
its mind from one day to the other… think
twice…
“Levanta la cabeza, Italia!
Estoy orgulloso de ser italiano.
Somos el mejor país del mundo y sólo necesitamos
un poco de trabajo y algo menos de impuestos”
Mateo Salvini
¡Ala!
¿Cómo os quedáis?
De repente, la Liga podía buscar votos en
toda Italia, tanto el Norte como el Sur.
Y ampliar el mercado siempre tiene ventajas.
Porque si pensabais que nadie te va a tomar
en serio si cambias tus principios fundamentales
de un día para otro… os equivocáis.
Victoria de la Liga en las elecciones italianas,
los tiempos están cambiando.
Pero si todavía no os ha volado la cabeza,
esperad a ver el siguiente actor de esta historia:
la izquierda populista italiana.
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
EL GRAN CHISTE
En el año 2009, Italia estaba en mitad de
una crisis enorme.
La Unión Europea quería que hicieran recortes
de presupuesto y el gobierno de Berlusconi
estaba en su peor momento.
Todo este contexto era el campo de cultivo
perfecto para fundar el MOVIMIENTO CINCO ESTRELLAS.
Durante estos años, un cómico que se llama
Beppe Grillo había empezado una plataforma
política a través de su blog.
Seguro que ni él se imaginaba en lo que terminaría
convirtiéndose.
Podríamos decir que el bautismo de fuego
de este movimiento fue en el año 2007, cuando
Beppe Grillo organizó el Vaffanculo day en
Bolonia.
Por si no lo habéis entendido, esto significa,
literalmente, el día de “vete a tomar por
culo”.
Se convirtió en un evento gigantesco, con
miles de personas firmando para cambiar la
ley electoral.
Querían evitar que los imputados pudieran
presentarse a elecciones parlamentarias.
Hasta aquí, todo normal.
Pero la auténtica oportunidad para Beppe
Grillo llegó unos años más tarde.
La economía italiana seguía de mal en peor.
Cada vez más italianos tenían que hacer
más esfuerzos para llegar a fin de mes.
Y aquí es cuando Italia nombra a su primer
ministro tecnócrata.
Exacto, hablamos del gobierno de Mario Monti.
Un tecnócrata es un político que dice no
tener ninguna ideología: simplemente se basa
en los conocimientos técnicos.
La tecnocracia Sin embargo, para muchos italianos,
Monti no era más que un títere de Bruselas,
que quería austeridad y recortes.
Y el partido que mejor capitalizó toda esta
rabia fue el Movimiento Cinco Estrellas.
Poco a poco, este partido ganó más alcaldías
y más puestos regionales.
En las elecciones de 2013 fueron el segundo
partido más votado, con más de 8 millones
de votos.
Todo esto era casi un milagro para un partido
tan joven.
Los resultados de las elecciones: enorme Victoria
para el movimiento 5 estrellas.
Euforia en Internet por el primer partido
en el Congreso de los Diputados.
Como decíamos, el Movimiento 5 estrellas
empezó como un partido anti stablishment.
De hecho, en un primer momento, muchos analistas
en España lo comparaban con Podemos.
Sin embargo, a diferencia de Podemos, los
italianos no tenían una ideología clara
ni una hoja de ruta.
Es más, a diferencia de Pablo Iglesias, Beppe
Grillo se apartó en seguida de la primera
línea política.
Y así es como, en 2016 llegó la primera
GRAN victoria.
“El movimiento 5 estrellas conquista Roma:
Raggi elegida alcaldesa con el 67% de los
votos: ´es un momento histórico y todos
los romanos han ganado´
Todo esto significa más expertos, ideólogos
y analistas que se embarcaron en este movimiento
para darle un corpus ideológico consistente.
Y así es como, poco a poco, la ideología
del Movimiento 5 estrellas se fue perfilando.
Su principal propuesta es la democracia directa.
Es decir, que los ciudadanos dejen de delegar
su poder en parlamentarios y puedan votar
en referéndums.
De hecho, el Movimiento 5 estrellas tiene
su propio sistema para hacer votaciones internas
por Internet.
Este sistema se llama ROUSSEAU y sirve para
que los afiliados puedan discutir ideas, propuestas
y aprobar proyectos.
Por ejemplo, en un momento, parecía que el
partido iba a adoptar posiciones anti inmigración.
El propio Bepe Grillo quería hacer algo así.
Sin embargo, hay que reconocer que la democracia
interna en este partido funciona…
Grillo, los votantes registrados del Movimiento
Cinco Estrellas han dicho NO a convertir la
inmigración ilegal en delito.
Pero, sin duda alguna, el auténtico cambio
en este partido llegó en 2017, con la llegada
de LUIGI DE MAIO a la dirección.
Este es el auténtico artífice del matrimonio
izquierda derecha que gobierna Italia.
Pero… ¿Cómo ha sido posible algo así?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
PAREJA LIBERAL
Hay una cosa muy importante que tenemos que
entender en Italia.
Aquí, los partidos políticos van y vienen
como si fueran un vídeo viral de moda.
Para que os hagáis una idea, desde el año
1946, Italia ha tenido 29 primeros ministros
distintos.
Esto significa que la media de un primer ministro
es de 2 años y medio.
Los partidos, prácticamente, se crean y se
destruyen elección tras elección.
Y esto significa que cada vez que hay unos
nuevos comicios, es muy difícil hacer predicciones.
Por ejemplo, en las últimas elecciones europeas,
parecía que la LIGA de Salvini estaba a punto
de desaparecer.
Unos años después y es uno de los partidos
más votados.
Si hay algo difícil en esta vida es explicarle
a un Italiano lo que significa “suelo electoral”.
Y por eso, en el año 2018, los partidos más
moderados se pegaron un auténtico batacazo.
La izquierda moderada del Partido Democrático
se quedó muy por debajo de lo que había
sido.
Y lo mismo pasó con el centro derecha de
Berlusconi.
Así que, los únicos que estaban dispuestos
a hacer una coalición eran los más populistas:
el movimiento 5 estrellas y La Liga.
Por supuesto, cada uno tiene su propia versión
de populismo.
Y sus propios feudos. 5 estrellas cosechó
casi todos sus votos en el Sur.
La Liga, por mucho que cambiara de nombre,
seguía teniendo casi todo su apoyo en el
Norte.
Pero ambos partidos capitalizaron el voto
protesta.
En otras palabras: las opciones moderadas
han perdido el fuelle.
Ahora lo que antes era outsider se ha convertido
en el nuevo mainstream.
Elecciones italianas: los populistas del Moviiento
Cinco Estrellas y la Liga se disputan el poder.
Pero como os podéis imaginar, este matrimonio
no fue tarea fácil.
Hicieron falta más de 10 semanas para que
se pusieran de acuerdo.
A fin de cuentas, habían sido adversarios
antes de las elecciones pero, por el otro
lado, podían sumar una mayoría en ambas
cámaras: congreso y senado.
Así que, finalmente, el movimiento 5 estrellas
trajo su 32% de los votos y la Liga su 17%.
Así es como empezó el nuevo gobierno de
Italia.
Y diréis ¿De verdad son capaces de entenderse
en una coalición?
¿Quién está traicionado a sus votantes?
Pues la respuesta es que, por el momento,
no tienen grandes problemas y cada uno, a
su manera, está cuidando a sus votantes.
Salvini está intentando, por todos los medios,
sacar leyes contra la inmigración y poner
un impuesto lineal del 15% para empresas e
individuos.
Los expertos dicen que esta reforma fiscal
dejaría a las arcas italianas con 80.000
euros menos cada año.
Y Di Maio parece aceptarlo si, a cambio, puede
plantar su reforma de renta básica.
Según las estimaciones, esta reforma costaría
17.000 millones de euros.
Sí, lo sé, el cálculo económico no funciona.
Pero la fórmula política parece funcionar.
Básicamente, podríamos decir que es como
una pareja abierta: están juntos pero, a
la vez, cada uno puede tener otras parejas.
En otras palabras, que aunque estén en coalición,
cada uno sigue intentando prepararse para
ganar más votos en las próximas elecciones.
Y lo cierto es que no parece que vaya a ser
tarea fácil.
La dolce vita parece a punto de desaparecer
de nuevo mientras Italia vuelve a la recesión
Exacto, Italia está en plena recesión.
Es más, justo en el momento en el que el
Primer Ministro, Giuseppe Conte, dijo que
Italia estaba a punto de tener un milagro
económico… Boom!
El PIB Italiano bajaba en un 0.2% en 2018.
Por el momento, el gobierno dice que todo
esto se debe… (((LEER CON IRONÍA))) al
ciclo económico europeo, que bueno, ya se
sabe… si quieres te lo miro…
Lo cierto es que el resto de países europeos
siguen creciendo mientras Italia decrece.
A eso se le llama tener problemas.
Y mientras tanto, estas políticas de gasto
pueden dar más que un dolor de cabeza para
el resto de europeos.
Pero todo esto es tema para otros vídeos.
Porque ahora la pregunta es: ¿Creéis que
sería posible una alianza similar en vuestro
país?
¿Por qué sí o por qué no?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Pero antes de terminar, dejadme que os hable
un poco sobre SQUARESPACE.
Si tienes un mensaje importante que trasladar,
puedes hacerlo con SQUARESPACE.
Quizás tengas la necesidad de tener una web
donde la gente pueda encontrarte, o quizás
acabas de crear tu propio negocio y necesitas
empezar a desarrollar tu presencia online
o tu propia tienda.
Bien.
Pues todo esto es posible gracias a SQUARESPACE.
En SQUARESPACE encontrarás plantillas para
tu web con diseños increíbles.
O, si a lo mejor no te interesan las plantillas
y tienes el talento y la creatividad para
diseñar tu mismo tu web… ¡También puedes
hacerlo por tu cuenta sin plantillas!
SQUARESPACE hace super fácil el poder construir
un espacio que resulte alucinante.
EN SQUARESPACE puedes registrar un dominio
nuevo o también mover uno que ya tengas.
El proceso no podría ser más sencillo.
Pero, si te surge cualquier duda, SQUARESPACE
ofrece un servicio de atención al cliente
24 horas donde encontrarás siempre alguien
que te pueda ayudar.
Lo dicho, si quieres tener tu propio espacio,
tu tienda online… ¡Lo que sea!
Hazlo realidad con SQUARESPACE.
Vete a SQUARESPACE.COM para una prueba gratuíta
y cuando lo tengas todo listo, vete a SQUARESPACE.COM/VISUALPOLITIKESP
para ahorrarte un 10% al adquirir tu primer
website o dominio.
Y como siempre, un abrazo y hasta pronto.